[Music]
this week we've got Jesse small/small a
update he's French small a small a small
a or small that small a small like three
Nazis and creepy acting outraged you're
putting this small in a weekend I didn't
play it there damn
Justin TIFF did I know I actually
there's so much information that it
deserves like its own but because it's a
follow-up to a JK's story that we've
already done I think that's why I want
to put it on we can scramble so I'm
gonna try to like follow up is so huge
they know I think there's gonna be more
follow up so maybe maybe you'll get
another song about the story I wanted
him to go to jail [ __ ] it up for a lot
of minorities yes by saying like
minorities I'm saying but what if one of
us we actually go through a hate crime
or whatever right yeah I mean it's like
yeah right you [ __ ] Jesse Smollett it
was but they dropped all the charges of
what happened oh sorry
okay so there is a video that explains
the original store if you want to go see
it we talked about on JK news but
basically Jesse Smollett tried to say
that some mago supporters some Trump
supporters but a noose around his neck
and we're like it's about a country and
they've chemicals in his face later we
find out that the attackers were people
that his friends knew his friends that
he actually wrote a check to for $3,500
and they were African American right so
they're not cheering together there was
a jury and he claims that that was for
personal trainers but basically he
didn't even say that he knew the
attacker exactly you know he was
claiming that he got attacked by Mogga
people who were like that smart country
okay they're African American by the way
so yeah he was using that they're not
cheering oh well this articles wrong
then
they're Nigerian they're not white is
the thing which is a picture that I
think he was trying to portray as he
said he got bleached pork I mean he got
caught is that they were buying all the
materials like the road trip all they
said right yeah scripts and stuff so how
do they get so he's still saying his
yeah there were 16 charges against him
and the the police the Chicago police
had a ton of evidence that were painting
this picture that he actually was you
know arranged the whole undeniable
evidence undeniable evidence and they
say the motive was so that he could get
more of a paycheck because he wasn't
satisfied with the $65,000 a week he was
getting paid oh you thought higher so we
thought maybe we have more of a name
exactly sixty-five thousand a week only
that's beautifully that's so beautiful
so all of a sudden that's not a kick my
ass
absolutely we have any association or
camera there's got to be a amount of
money that you're not considered a
minority anymore after you make yeah
because you're now in this alley five
thousand a week is there sixty five to
zero you're in the minority of rich no
like there's no there's no downgrade
you're a privileged minority is what it
is now why did they drop all this so
basically the Chicago prosecutor is the
state prosecutors that hot all these
charges against him just dropped the
case out of nowhere like drops it sealed
the case I've Nora yeah these sealed
isn't you can't even go into it and they
really a [ __ ] they offered like no
explanation for it either
basically what rich privileged yeah the
mayor of Chicago is infuriated yeah he's
like what the [ __ ] cuz everyone
basically got blindsided so the
policeman who was the judge that said
this was okay doesn't say the judge's
name were basically they brokered a deal
behind everyone's back so the lawyers of
of Jesse smaller came up with the deal
behind everyone's back the police force
didn't even know about it because they
were in the middle of police graduation
when the news broke so they found out
about it like after everybody else and
they were super pissed rightfully so
Jesse did agree to give up ten thousand
dollars
which was nothing compared to the amount
of money they spent on the police force
the investigation they forfeit that bail
to the city target but he's like that's
basically a smack in the face because
you spent way more
yeah they spent so much of the city's
money on investigating this case because
they were like this is a real hate crime
so they want to stop hate crimes and
they put a bunch of the city's resources
and resources into finding how does that
make you feel like what he was saying is
true or not true what who was saying
Jesse Jesse uh not true cuz why would
you why would you give up ten thousand
dollars if you're still innocent and he
maintains that he's still innocent
and being like see wow they drop all the
charges nobody knows and so the only you
can't even get into the files to go back
into the evidence because they [ __ ]
shut they sealed it and so that's it's
so skeptical right now to because it's
so funny because even the prosecutor who
dropped the charges stated publicly I
don't he is not innocent like I do not
believe he is it I still think he's able
to how they let him off like this yes
the craziest thing Million Dollar Man
privileged yeah like he's not important
because the crazy thing is it's like
there's not a single person even the
prosecutor doesn't think that this
[ __ ] is innocent but he after
this key comes out he goes I knew I was
innocent this holding nobody said you
were innocent but he thinks you're
innocent he went out and he started
taking selfies with his fans yeah I mean
there's still a small group that is like
hey congrats and stuff but the only
explanation the prosecutors gave was
that they go after violent criminals and
they just didn't think that jesse was of
a violent person yeah so he did some
community service he is violent because
like no [ __ ] normal person in their
right mind does [ __ ] like that I don't
know I mean this is me to a degree like
check this out in a glove thing it's he
did a crime against himself right a lot
Hoople around it that's [ __ ]
but like at the end the day he didn't
assault nobody or knowing that assaulted
him like who's pressing
well you did commit a crime because it's
fragile it's it's you you wasted police
resources to try crime wolf but he
didn't tell the police to like use all
his resources even if he did he walked
into the police station and then he just
didn't know that they were gonna do so
much investigating they decision you're
gonna do that you can't do that in
Chicago you got to be like in some small
town with like three police cars please
Sports boy oh yeah like last night or
just never [ __ ] me never do it yeah who
would think that was a good idea so the
mayor is pissed because he's like not
only did use all these resources but you
also dragged Chicago's name like we have
like a bunch of a Chicago is not cool
both here in like Concord they're
already dealing with that and trying to
like solve those problems and get rid of
hate crimes and like here he is like
perpetuating them basically but one
silver lining is that he could stay
still face federal charges because the
FBI and the US Postal Service are still
continuing to probe into this letter
that US Postal Service
yeah because remember when he sent a
letter to himself oh I'm sending a
letter to himself so though he got a
letter with some white powder in it
which turned out to be like crushed
Tylenol or something oh yeah and it said
in like magazine cut out letters oh geez
what so this was saw the Batman movie
with Val Kilmer I'm gonna do that do you
don't you think that could be mental
health problems I know they do clearly
psycho and then in the return address it
just said Marga by God villainous
villain of Mogga people yeah I hope they
jump in right what would you I thought
some other like friends of my industry
that we are kind of like around it we
know love whatever we're all kind of
connected right and uh and actors of
color you know saying like and we're
like why would he do this like how is it
self do you want like what we've all you
know we all in the industry and
everyone's on the chase for like paper
and fame and fortune on whatever is part
of the the psyche of everyone come in to
Holly
but to this degree let's see he's a
crazy person it's really yeah yeah did
you see his interview where he's like
trying to cry and stuff no like I'm I
I'm I'm uh my mother's son you know
basically he's don't bring your mom into
this you should hit back I would not be
my mother's son if I did a drop of what
I've been accused yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know what it is it's like does
anybody believe them anymore but you
know like but if you was if you may you
go through all these auditions you tell
me you haven't met the most craziest
human beings than our actors and
actresses like they're [ __ ] ah there's
a [ __ ] batshit crazy a longtime his
family you know you're like one of the
most famous actor that I know that's
true you're very down-to-earth yeah
well cuz we could you live longer you're
in the industry the more you can just
understand [ __ ] you didn't get [ __ ]
chewed out and spit out like some of
these people you're also a child actor
to everyone has like you know has yeah
sorry everyone has a dark side but I
mean you you're well put together
compared to a lot of child actors I
appreciate that but you know [ __ ] he has
no pants diksa guys like he was really
chill at one point okay so next story
there's I'm sure there's gonna be more
on the Jesse small because as I said
they're investigating so maybe I think
the for me I'm like well if it really
did happen he is innocent why don't we
catch the real ready right there's no
one talking about that who already
admitted to being the people that
attacked him yeah can he charge it at
all yeah what the hell is that it's
already there a lot of mystery involved
in this case this is crazy all [ __ ] up
it's reliving a crazy time something
happened in time war another world
we all went the whole woods went crazy
well here's the original prosecutor she
had to get kicked off the case because
an Obama aide reached out to her and
they found out that she was like talking
to small it's family and all this stuff
so it's it's just really weird there's a
lot of weird things to us aids she was
off the casing that she was back on the
cases that's all weird there's something
happening behind closed doors
but no longer and the president yeah but
he's still got presidential everything
though I still got some me I think like
afterwards even after you put there
still protect me
yeah just Secret Service from I play by
a different set of rules than the rest
of my rich people though yeah but yes
help I think he has some help because
from some families be surprised he's
still on the show right no yeah what God
written off the show originally when he
was getting charged but then recently
the show tweeted see you on Wednesday
with a winky found an article saying all
the charges were dropped it might not be
him but there's people's jobs on the
line for him oh what a [ __ ] what
shows not getting canceled but yeah but
they're like yeah we're happy to find
out the news about the charges being
dropped crazy why you stupid okay let's
talk about Nazi Krispy Kremes okay I
love Krispy Kremes ones
the hot ones the family that owns Krispy
Kremes they recent and Panera Bread they
lose family well they bought it was like
a company that owned Panera Bread they
also bought and acquired crispy oh
really that family that businesses they
learned that their ancestors supported
Hitler and used Russian civilians and
French prisoners war as forced laborers
when they originally opened a factory
for Panera Bread all tweets are saying
the Bush family banked the [ __ ] Nazi
so don't worry Disney was a [ __ ]
support well that's I think that was a
conspiracy like the Mickey Mouse Nazi
cartoon I heard that that was not real
okay well I don't know about the car too
and I just knew about him I've never
even heard about that I heard that he
was like a ghost or something
I mean you can't be responsible for
eight generations ago or I mean like
even you know just hear what your
grandpa days yeah we don't even know
what this generation's gonna look like
20 years from now we could be in some
really dark stuff we're gonna be like
who who was who supported it that's like
saying
like saying my brother murdered someone
so I should go to jail yeah yeah well
they're just ashamed the pant ow that's
uh cuz that's a that's a very crazy
statement that's happened like with with
blocks you know nemi where white people
are like bro why are you like landing me
for one my gram like my ancestors did
that's not saying we should we should
stop that - I don't know generations let
us carry over and yeah you can't erase
like feelings and stigma well then only
Chinese people should be able to use the
trains because we built those crimes on
someone else that's weird you know it is
weird
I can understand hard feelings like we
get that but you can't bring that into a
legal sense like that's where it gets
weird so no one's like going after them
or anything they're not no one's like
outraged but the family themselves were
just disgusted to learn that and they
they said that disgust at themselves
they're disgusted that their family
members believe in him they put it out
there yeah yeah I think it's just guilt
like you know that white guilt you know
like it's what kills me all slaves back
then they're like why would you tell
people that Japanese people [ __ ] it
Japanese people did some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
nothing to do with me
has nothing to do with me yeah Death
March
you got my people from 1-5 Island and
you walk them [ __ ] the hell am i
dying in a human sin just kill I'm
saying on a human level it sucks right
it sucks like you mean you know like a
lot of people there was genocides what
happened to the Jewish people it sucks
right but for me does have to stand here
and say I am sorry for what Japanese
people did [ __ ] that [ __ ] I'm born in
America put you in an internment camp
yeah I don't see but that's still that's
out they put my like [ __ ] uncle and
one or whatever but I'm like why should
why people apologize to me right no feel
sorry for me because my uncle went in
there [ __ ] that you know have that guy
who put my uncle in say sorry I'm and
they [ __ ] deal with it
this thing I said basically like knife
something crazy like 99% of people
everybody the history of time if they
can enslave another culture or person
they'll do it they'll do 99% will go the
blacks Africa's they enslaved themselves
yeah that's what the white people got
the idea for it's like look cool like
they it's just how it goes and I got and
I was like that's crazy it's just human
nature
everyone's tribal by nature and so I'll
take over another tribe and I say I'll
prove it to you even us today to think
I'll we're above doing [ __ ] to other
people like if you have the opportunity
you will take it say your house goes on
a bubble and you know burgers gonna pop
you don't care who buys this house you
know that house is not worth a million
dollars like a $500,000 house [ __ ] the
next person they can have the house job
I'm gonna take the money they can be a
sweet-looking business there's so many
[ __ ] like rules and regulations for
your employees
cuz bosses take [ __ ] advantage of
totally you know but that's the kind of
basic excellent systems like anytime
there's a shift in power like that
though they treat the human yeah exactly
they make it like so these memory yeah
we need a child tell Avery laws because
because we would hire crazy you know we
have machines scum of the earth it's not
humans we have machines built for child
labor and we we had the Industrial
Revolution here in the US and then
little tiny machines yeah you don't used
to work six days a week
Chinese kids Japanese kids no in America
yeah kids no America we we would we
would dad kids would work in the
factories here that's why we had to come
up with child labor laws we would work
six days a week the only free day we had
off was to go to church we as in
Americans right and then um I think it
was Ford the the car manufacturer he
came up with a system of either the
eight hour work week or the eight hour
work day or like it or he changed it to
five day work I don't know but he
revolutionized some [ __ ] a lot of people
were evolutionized some [ __ ] that we
take granite for we don't know yeah
thank God yeah grandparents [ __ ]
the press now we have more problems and
we're like creating problems [ __ ] all
that [ __ ] lastly in the movie us that
just recently came out a lot gee I don't
want to watch yeah I won't spoil
anything for you so I haven't seen it
but you see it's article will not spoil
anything for you
other than the fact that one of the lead
actresses Lupita Nyong'o yeah thank you
I didn't know how to pronounce that
young girl her voice during one of the
characters is inciting online outrage
and that's because she plays two
characters in the movie she plays a
character named a delayed and it's that
she's a mom on vacation and then read
who was a demon who's basically adel
it's evil doppelganger but when she
plays this red character she goes into
this whole voice have you seen it okay
so tell me nothing is the voice really
scary so it sounds like a smoker okay
Magnus kind of it's very husky and
what's wrong with the voice well so the
reason it's dick inciting outrage mokroe
Seamus she says that she got the
inspiration from a disease called
spasmodic dysphonia it's a neural it's
not a disease it's a neurological
disorder and so neurological yeah
neurological disorder and so people with
this disease hey why don't you make it
better that's a fashion show and she saw
Robert Kennedy speak and he had that
voice and so she's like oh that's the
voice and then she she told people
people with the disorder got mad because
they're like yo that's my life like why
are you making it an evil character and
so they're just mad that advocates
like [ __ ] you already scary that's fine
yeah yeah so they're like oh thanks a
lot like you hold on a second oh but
this is this is kind of [ __ ] gun too
because what do you expect actors to do
they're gonna grab inspiration from
everything around everything don't tell
your secrets so no one get pissed I know
it's [ __ ] do it and then don't okay
I'm just [ __ ] things up right now all
right hold on a second
continue please yeah don't tell your
secret if someone's got hate on you well
she went more detail to where she found
out that spasmodic dysphonia was a
psychological disorder that was caused
by trauma which actually isn't true it
has been proven to be a neurological
disorder later on but when she thought
it was psychological she's like oh great
because my character went through a lot
of trauma and so now she's this like
creepy demon like talks like that
character and so people were like dude
it's not a psychological we can't just
get rid of it let's see actually
neurological and we can't control that
voice that comes out if you're a no that
sucks what it's weird yeah yeah that's
my excuse like it's like Matt oh I'm
sorry but it's weird
and I'm immature and I think it's funny
what's like how you can't pretend to be
you can't pretend have Down syndrome
right now I know what I think it's funny
I know what you can say is after you
don't tell nothing you just be like yeah
I just where did you get your
interpreter winsome inspiration and
children I just thought why are people
judging us like it's a factual
documentary like it's an inaccurate
portrayal of spaz or whatever phone is
it's a [ __ ] fictional movie yeah
and she says that oh it's not gonna
exactly mirror the qualities of this
distortions go on to [ __ ] I don't even
know how deep she went into the research
of that little thing for the boys
studied with the doctor and also yeah
like a larynx person and then also a
speech dialect coach and did her job
that's dope
she did she wanted to nail the voice
without ruining
that's why I like tennis too accurate
that's like Liam Neeson right he didn't
have to tell that [ __ ] reporter he
wanted to kill a black man what would
you say that was like you know she's
trying to do that flex yeah I get that
flex yeah
wait a second unnecessary flex people
are like you know it's a real disability
and it affects my ability to have a job
and it affects your social unnecessary
but unless Lupita yeah exactly
I can't they look at it on the brighter
side okay if she's mimicking this and
she's killing these acting roles why
don't all these people with this
disability go out and act and be
villains and all the other it was that
one guy in the 90s that always played
the [ __ ] guy Joe little person you
know the guy who [ __ ] what Conan
what's the PC term it's a little person
I think no person was derogative now
just own your [ __ ] I don't like people
that like play victim like if that
opened up the door owners should go do
that they don't know how to think that
way because they're depressed right yeah
and some people some people are like hey
I wouldn't have even known about this
disorder yeah wasn't for all this
outrage because only 50,000 people get
diagnosed with it what year yeah cuz you
know the minute like a movie is hot like
crazy rich Asians all of a sudden
Hollywood is looking for every sexy
asian dude out there to open up another
series yet to hit us up so if she killed
it on being the villain in this movie
they're gonna look for anyone that could
also do this voice and there are people
that can naturally do this voice but the
voice it's just it's literally damn
that's insensitive David how can you do
that dude i watch the film it's like
that yeah looks legit I'm not probably
doing as well as her because I haven't
haven't talked about that's pretty good
though ya know research exactly so
so Lupita I could have taken your role
just let you know
[Music]